today on the matt wall show congress is
back in session and the democrats have
started the new year on an especially
stupid note which we'll have to discuss
today also five headlines including the
squad
the entire squad bending the need in
nancy pelosi and the mayor of portland
apparently has decided that actually he
doesn't want lawless hooligans to rule
his city anymore it might be too little
too late for that and in our daily
cancellation we will cancel cosmo for
claiming
that obesity is not just beautiful but
healthy all of that and more coming up
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it's not easy to be an adult
because being an adult means you have to
be responsible you got to take care of
business there's a lot of pressure on
you
and that's but you know grow up that's
part that's part of being an adult
that's what it means it also means
getting life insurance when you have
people who depend on your income and
it's not just being an adult that's
being if you're a parent a spouse got to
take care of the people
that you love and who love you policy
genius makes it easy for you to compare
more than 30 top insurers at once and
save over 50 in the process plus there's
no hassle because their license experts
work for you not for the insurance
companies here's how it works it's very
easy
first you head to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and you can compare
quotes from top insurers and then policy
units will compare policies starting at
as little as a dollar a day
you might even be eligible to skip the
in-person medical exam you don't know
until you until you go and try once you
apply the policy genius team will handle
all the paperwork and red tape if you
hit any speed bumps along the way during
the application process they'll take
care of everything so it's really easy
for you the main thing you got to do is
just go to policy policygenius.com
and almost everything else all the hard
stuff anyway is taken care of by the
policy genius team
and this is the kind of service that has
earned policy genius a five-star rating
across 1600 reviews on trustpilot and
google
and uh you know you know you can trust
that i mean list don't listen to me
listen to what people who
listen to what the people are saying um
make it this is what you want to do this
year this is like this i think is a good
new year's resolution for all of us make
it the year you finally cross life
insurance off your list and get
protection for your loved ones go to
policygenius.com and get started you
could save 50 or more by comparing
quotes and start the new year with one
less thing to worry about policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right
so the first session of the 117th
congress was open yesterday with much
ceremony and fanfare this congress i'm
sure
promises to be about as productive as
the 116 that came before it might be a
little unfair there were a couple good
ones in there
but
credit to the democrats for coming out
boldly to start the new session and the
new year and declaring at the outset
their intention
to take their lunacy and stupidity to
new and unfathomable heights
setting the bar
for us was a a democrat representative
an ordained methodist minister
who delivered a prayer
a prayer which
started out okay and and was mostly fine
throughout
until it got to the end
and here's what that sounded like we
asked it in the name of the monotheistic
god
brahma
and god known by many names by many
different faiths
a man
and a woman
that by the way was representative
emmanuel
cleaver
or representative
e womenial cleaver as he no doubt calls
himself or should call himself now
and as you just heard in an attempt to
be inclusive and politically correct
cleaver addresses the prayer to the
monotheistic god and also brahma the
hindu god randomly then he closes it
with a hearty amen and a woman
and there are many problems here but
let's focus on just two of them first of
all
i'm skeptical in general of ecumenical
approaches to prayer and worship even
among just christians but certainly
there is there is no way to apply that
philosophy
to all of the world religions together
you know uh with all due respect to the
co-exist bumper sticker praying to the
monotheistic god and brahma is like
writing a love letter to your wife and
addressing it to to whom it may concern
your attempt to cover all the bases and
be as generalized and vague as possible
defeats the whole purpose of the
exercise worse it only insults and
degrades the person in this case the
deity you're supposed to be expressing
your devotion to
you know god brahma vishnu zeus whatever
your name is
you're better off not praying if that's
how you're going to pray
but of course this wasn't really a
prayer at all and not intended to be
rather rather than being an expression
of humble submission before the almighty
which is what prayer is meant to be it
was intended as a symbolic and
self-aggrandizing display of
enlightenment to the world
so rather than saying
god we adore you the prayer was really
saying hey world don't you adore us get
a load of us look how enlightened we are
and it fails even on its own terms
anyway after all if you're going to be
inclusive by naming random gods in your
prayer then you really have to name them
all don't you
cleaver prays to brahma and the
monotheistic god which i suppose is
supposed to cover
christianity judaism islam and hinduism
but he failed to mention for example the
zoroastrian god uhuru mazda
um the aztec sun god
uh hutzelpaktali or any of the hundreds
of other gods featured in the religions
of the world
inclusiveness is almost always a losing
game because once you start trying to be
inclusive
you have to be completely inc inclusive
or else you you've only made the
exclusion of certain groups all the more
obvious and pronounced
so ahura mazda
might feel excluded if you just pray to
the lord jesus christ but think of how
he must feel now if you start mentioning
other random deities yet still fail to
acknowledge him
it's kind of like in school you know if
one of the kids in your class was
invited to a birthday party and you
weren't
it was only mildly upsetting
but if 15 kids were invited and you
still weren't it was a tragedy
and this is what inclusiveness
inclusiveness gets you
but we haven't yet of course discussed
the dumbest aspect of this prayer which
is amen and a woman
now amen
is originally a hebrew word and it
passed through greek and latin before
entering english
through all of these languages beginning
with its biblical hebrew origins it has
meant
so be it or let it be so or truthfully
okay its meaning has varied slightly in
modern usage it's come to also mean
something like i agree
when shouted from the church pews during
the minister's sermon but
it does not now have and has never at
any point had
a gendered meaning
yes it has the word men in it but that
is purely incidental
again this this comes from the hebrew
and in scripture when jesus says amen i
say to you he's not saying hey dudes i'm
saying to you and when a prayer ends
with amen it doesn't mean
dude's rock or bro power or whatever the
democrats apparently imagine it to mean
it was already an entirely inclusive and
neutral word the democrats here have
added gender to a genderless word
even while trying to remove gender from
gendered words
so the same people who gave us la tinx
because they don't like the gendered
connotation of latino and latina have
now given us a woman to infuse gender
into a word that
where it didn't previously exist in fact
the democrats just this weekend this is
how absurd it is okay
just this weekend they also introduced
new rules to strip away all official
mentions of gender-specific words so
words like man woman mother son
all would be banned under the the new
rules the office of the whistleblower um
ombudsman would become the office of the
whistleblower ombuds
campaign manager would be
campaign personager
i made that last one up but don't put it
past them i'm sure it's what's coming
next the point is as i have observed
many times when it comes to gender as
with so many other things leftism is
totally incoherent
it can't keep its own agenda straight it
can't help but contradict itself at
every turn one minute they're they're
making things genderless the next minute
they're making them gendered one minute
they're telling us that the word woman
doesn't really mean anything anyway the
next minute they're
asking us to applaud women simply for
existing and we'll have more on that in
the five headlines in just a second
in a word the left is
confused and they seek to spread that
confusion they want us to join them
in their intellectual and moral fog
they extend the invitation
and wish to make its acceptance
mandatory
and that is all the more reason to
resist
let's go to our five headlines
[Music]
all right i'm i'm i am enjoying this
this i have to say just a quick note on
football if you're not a football fan
bear with me but i'm enjoying this
controversy with uh with the new york
giants who are very upset their fans are
very upset
uh because they're missing the playoffs
because the eagles played the team
formerly known as the redskins last
night and um eagles are four and 11 you
know going or i guess we're four and ten
going into the game out of playoff
contention and uh they lost and so now
the team formerly knows the redskins is
going to enter the playoffs at seven and
nine they said they've they've lost more
games than they won
um and the claim is that the eagles uh
basically forfeited the game or through
the game because they figure well what's
the point of winning i'd rather we'd
rather lose one more game and and get
better draft position i don't know if
it's true if they threw the game or not
and even if they did i'm not sure i
could blame them like what is the point
of winning at the end of the season if
you're gonna you know sacrifice three or
four positions in the draft and it might
make probably throwing the game makes
more sense and should probably happen
more often it's probably what i would do
if i was in charge of a team um but
anyway the giants are upset because
because of of the team formerly known as
redskins win now the giants don't make
it into the playoffs and so they're
blaming the the eagles for for for
throwing the game well the giants are
six and ten
they lost ten games
it's true they could have made the
playoffs if the if the game against the
with the giants and the the redskins and
the eagles had gone differently but
talk about entitlement you're six and
ten and upset that you didn't make the
playoffs and blaming someone else
blaming another team
for not getting you into the playoffs at
six and ten
it's absurd this is why i think we need
to get rid of divisions in the nfl
because having even a seven and nine
team make the playoffs is a is just a
joke
and a disgrace but let's move on nancy
pelosi speaking of jokes and disgraces
was elected to
serve once again as speaker of the house
and this makes i believe her i think
it's her 2000th term she's actually the
only member of congress who started her
career
on the senate in ancient rome
and now she's going to return and here
she is
addressing the house here's what she had
to say
it gives me great pride to serve as
speaker of the most diverse
house of representatives in the history
of our country with a record shattering
122
women
122 women
you can applaud that
122 women
100 years
after women won the right to vote
yes applaud
just like we were talking about in the
opening to applaud women just for
existing so applauding the women and
notice see here's the thing
everybody in the chamber there stood for
this there's a standing ovation if you
weren't watching if you're listening it
was a standing ovation to women just
just because they're women just why not
a standing ovation for all women
um and everyone in the chamber of course
not surprisingly stood for the standing
ovation i'm at the point
where where
and of course republicans too presumably
you know there are some republicans
there they stood also
i'm at the point where
like my only litmus test is for a
republican is
um
will you stand for something like that
i'm at the point where i almost don't
even care what your other positions are
if you will just simply not applaud in a
situation like that i think i would i
would vote to make you president i don't
even care anything else about you
because i think that tells me everything
i need to know at least you're better
than all the rest of these clowns
no if you're in the room and so
outstanding applaud women don't just
just keep sitting
not because of anything against women
but because that's completely silly and
patronizing
and so you should just sit there and
roll your eyes
i will vote i will i will
vote for president
the first republican
in in a situation like that who rather
than stand and applaud just sits and
rolls their eyes because that is the
appropriate response
um
but by the way speaking of nancy pelosi
as the daily wire notes
all six members of the congressional
squad
did vote to make her speaker of the
house um six members
now wait a second
how were there i thought there were
six
i thought there were four where did the
six come from um okay congresswoman
ilhan omar we know about her
congresswoman
rashida talib
congresswoman ayanna presley we know
about her you know she's kind of like
the blue power ranger the one nobody
really likes that much um and
congresswoman
aoc alexandra quezo cortez so they all
voted for pelosi as they did back in the
2019 speaker election where do we get
the other squad members now i'm just
distracted by this
congresswoman corey bush and congressman
jamal bowman
are the two newest squad members so
there's a dude in the squad now
you just you can't do this going back to
the power rangers analogy
it's like adding a purple and orange
power ranger you can't do it we've
already the squad is set i i feel upset
about this actually
i don't like this it's i i like the
original squad
it has certain symmetry to it
you knew the role of each one
now you just start adding more in i mean
next thing you know there's going to be
50 people on the squad it just doesn't
work
uh too many cooks blowing the broth you
might say but in any case they all this
this these are the the radical new young
revolutionary
uh leftists the socialists the marxists
and they're all lining up bowing down
kissing the ring
no big surprise there
number two representative don young a
republican had um
had some supposedly inspiring words to
share
as congress opened its new session
uh this is this was being shared a lot
on on on twitter and making the rounds
online a lot of people liked it because
it was very bipartisan and unifying
um i kind of have a problem with it
maybe that won't surprise you to learn
but here it is
man and speaker before i
issue the oath i'd like to take
privilege of the floor as the dean
i've been in this house longer than
anybody else
i've served with you longer than anybody
else has served with you
i love this institution
i will be honest i do not like what i
see
it's time we hold hands and talk to one
another and man and speaker i say this
with all sincerity you will be the
speaker of the house
not of a party
that may hurt some of you
the job of our nation is for the house
of representatives to govern this nation
it was never meant to be
the executive branch
it was never meant to be the judicial
branch it's this house
that raises the money and dedicates how
it shall spend and we are representing
the people as we're elected and i say
this and also consider madam speaker
that
when you do have a problem or if there's
something so contentious let's sit down
and have a drink
well nancy pelosi would certainly have
no problem sitting down for a drink i'm
sure
uh but
and and also by the way the the
executive branch is supposed to govern
that's literally what the executive
branch is supposed to do
but um as far as holding hands and
talking to each other
uh i'm i'm not into that i have to tell
you now don young
you can do that and i think that there
are there's no shortage of republicans
in congress
who are willing to hold hands and talk
be led by the hand that's the thing when
you hold hands and you talk to the left
they're they're they're leading you in a
direction
they're not just standing there they're
they're gonna they're gonna guide you
they'd be perfectly fine holding hands
with you and bringing you right over the
cliff
so i'm not going to do that now holding
hands in general like i don't want to
hold anyone's hand if they're not my
wife or my child even in church
or sometimes you go and you you're
sitting around the table you know some
some families are more you know
touchy-feely and uh they do the thing
where you say grace before and
everyone's supposed to hold hands while
saying grace i'm not into that
um so i won't even hold hands in those
circumstances i certainly am not going
to hold hands
with someone on the left
who despises me
and everything i believe in everything i
stand for
so putting aside any concerns about
personal space
that's the real issue here
what what are we going to talk about
the idea of bipartisanship or unity or
all of us getting along the idea of
everybody getting along sounds good to
me
i like the idea of it
if i could just snap my fingers and make
everyone get along i probably would
maybe i wouldn't because it'd be kind of
boring but
i'd at least consider it
the the problem though is that we're
dealing with with people
who that's not what they're interested
in again if you're a conservative
they despise you
and everything you believe and
everything you stand for they hate
fundamentally
so what is there to talk about
no i'm not interested in holding hands
with somebody like that i'm not really
interested in
talking to them
i'll fight for my position
for my stance for my beliefs
but just sitting down and you know
having a friendly chat
um
i don't see how we do that
but i know democrat republicans more
than happy to do it
and
yeah it doesn't surprise me don young
says he's been there longer than anybody
else
i'll be honest i don't know anything
about him
but that doesn't surprise me alone
either
the republicans that have been there
that long what have they done
what have they done in terms of actually
resisting and standing up to the
democrats not much
now
there's one example of
cowardly
republicans let's go to
the other side here this is from a few
days ago over the break but i wanted to
play it in case you missed it
because i think it helps to build my
case for ron desantis 2024.
um here's what ron desantis said there's
a a clear change in tone here
from what most lawmakers have said about
the vaccine to what ron desantis had to
say here he is listen
what i've said is um i'm willing to take
it but i am not the priority they're the
priority i'm under 45
and so the people under 45
are not going to be first in line for
this and so when it's my turn um i will
take it um but this is who i want to be
vaccinated i want my parents our
grandparents to be able to get it and
you know granted i mean i'm an elected
official but what do you do at the end
of the day let's focus where the risk is
i love that i'm an elected official but
whoopty do
exactly right
that's why right now ron desantis
my personal favorite uh right now for
for 2024 and look a lot can happen in
the meantime so it's
and especially with politicians they can
find many ways to become themselves in
the span of four minutes let alone four
years i'm not saying that ronda sanders
will do that but i also don't know that
he won't that's why you know i've always
preached you never get too attached to
politicians you never
uh
we hear this
among conservatives now we hear a lot
and it's kind of disturbing to me this
idea of loyalty now you have to be loyal
loyal to the president loyal no we
we're not supposed to be loyal to
politicians they're supposed to be loyal
to us we don't have to be loyal to them
that's loyalty really with politicians
it's supposed to be a one-way street
them to us not the other way around
so um there's no loyalty here but right
now with how it stands if he keeps this
up then i love ron desantis for um
for 2024 exactly for
things like that
now number four the mayor of portland
ted wheeler
could take some leadership lessons from
ron desantis
he is finally after six months of
lawlessness
he has
finally decided that maybe it would be
better if insane criminals weren't
running amok in the streets of his city
but it might be a little too late
too little and too late i think for this
but but here it is
my good faith efforts
at de-escalation
have been met with ongoing violence
and even scorn
from radical antifa and anarchists
in response
it will be necessary to use additional
tools and to push the limits of the
tools we already have to bring the
criminal destruction and violence to an
end
lawlessness and anarchy
come at great expense
and with great risk to the future of our
community
it's time to push back harder
against those who are set on destroying
our community and to take more risks in
fighting lawlessness
in closing once again
i condemn anyone who engages in violence
or criminal destruction no matter what
their ideology
you know what gets me about that here's
what jumps out of me when i watch that
is uh
he looks like he's about to cry
now
granted ted willer's the kind of man who
just always looks like he's about to
break down in tears or maybe just was in
the pre like he always looks like the
guy a guy who just was weeping in the
bathroom and just came out and is about
to run back in and cry again
uh but it's never more obvious than
right now he really seems like he's on
the verge of tears because he's really
upset and he's he's hurt
he's uh he's his feelings are hurt
and he's kind of right in a way because
what he's saying is
look i've done everything for these
people i've i've tried to give them
everything they want and they still hate
my guts
they chase me out of my apartment
they're they're protesting me at my
house
i've done i have bent over backwards for
these people
to give them everything they want and
it's still not enough
and he's very upset about that
um and on that
end of it he's actually right
he has given them everything they want
he has let them run through the streets
and he's let them do literally anything
they want
i think we could put it like that
anything they want to include burning
down buildings
killing people looting
and he's let them do it for months on
end
and it's still not enough
it is never enough
and the thing is eventually everyone
learns this
even a doltish useless incompetent
buffoon
like this clown
he eventually learned it it took him six
months to learn but but eventually he
did
that when it comes to these
leftist radicals it will never be there
is nothing you can do there is nothing
you can give them there is no concession
you can make that will ever satisfy them
ever
and so for that reason alone you might
as well just stand up and say no
because whether you say no now or you
finally say no six months from now or a
year from now when you're fed up with it
the response is going to be the same
so you might as well preserve your
dignity
ted wheeler i mean let this be a lesson
this is a
a tragic lesson for us all this is a man
who has completely forfeited his dignity
and his honor as a man
and now he stands before us weeping and
broken
and hated by everybody
that's what you get
ted
that's what you get
don't mean to victim blame but there it
is um number five here's a report from
new york post this is from this this
happened
back right before the new year but i've
had it saved here because i wanted to
mention it when we got back on the air
new york post reports
a sculpture honoring police shooting
victim brianna taylor
was smashed by vandals over the weekend
prompting a probe by oakland police
according to two reports the memorial
installed uh two weeks ago in downtown
uh latham square was smashed in several
places sometime on saturday this was a
couple saturdays ago
the bust includes a plaque that reads
say her name brianna taylor
the artist leo carson says at first i
was stunned and shocked and hurt and
angry
just a whole bunch of emotions it felt
like i was personally attacked and also
they attacked brianna taylor in the blm
movement
oakland police said in a statement that
a report had been filed
in the vandalism of the taylor bust and
that police were investigating the
incident
and there was a
there's a gofundme now and there was a
reward put out i'm not sure what the
latest is on this actually i don't know
if they found
the the vandal but two points about this
um number one
why was there a statue of brianna taylor
in the first place
i'm sort of asking that rhetorically
because i know but
what did brianna taylor
do with her life to earn a statue or
a monument
i mean generally what we do is is we or
at least in the past we've built statues
and monuments for people who accomplish
great things
all of these statues that are being torn
down
in most cases
these are people who earn those statues
because they did great
consequential things because they
reshaped
human history
you know because because our lives are
different today and better
because they existed
that's the kind of thing that earns you
a statue and that's why i'm a
post-attached statue's being torn down
with brianna taylor though it's not
clear to me exactly what she did to to
earn it other than the fact that she was
killed in a police shooting
see i don't know if that's really enough
or should be enough to earn a statue but
the second point is
look these are the new rules now right
these are the rules if you don't like a
statue you can just destroy it
are we supposed to be outraged and
offended by this
i'm sorry i got to tell you i'm not i
have to tell you i don't care at all
that they smash the brianna taylor
statue i don't care at all because the
rules now i didn't make these rules the
left has made the rules and the rule is
if you don't like a statue you can just
destroy it now i know they intend for
that rule only to apply to them
but no see that game is over that's
that's a new year's resolution we can
all make for 2021. that game is over you
don't get to have your own rules you
don't get to make exceptions for
yourself if you're saying this is the
way it's going to be now for you it's
going to be this way for everybody
if you're allowed to tear down the
statues you don't like anybody else can
i don't know who tore down the statue
who destroyed it but they're allowed to
now
according to you
the logic that you have applied it's
going to go across the board
if you don't like that i mean and you
know i
that this isn't the world that i want to
live in i don't want to live in a world
where you could just destroy whatever
property you want
um
but this wasn't my idea
if you're on the left this was your
ideas what you wanted so
embrace it
this is all on you
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation just a second but a quick
bonus item here um before we get to our
daily cancellation i wanted to to play
this for you also um because i thought
it would be great to start the year with
uh
well just with beauty
and grace for a change
because it's going to be a rough year i
think um but we want to try to begin on
the right foot so to speak so here is uh
speaking of beauty and grace and grace
here's a video of of myself my wife
took this video
and posted it
online to try to embarrass me uh to
shame me publicly but the joke's on her
because
this is a video that she took this past
weekend
when we went with the family uh to a
spot in the city to do some ice skating
now i have never ice skated before in my
life okay
first time ever never done it so my wife
was filming hoping that i would fall
okay this she would that's she was
praying for the fall and that she could
get that on on tape and then put it on
twitter but it didn't work out instead
let's just take a look at this let's
play the clip here i want everyone to
see this go ahead and play it
um
and if you're just listening to the
audio you're gonna look at this look at
the gracefulness
have you ever seen now again i've never
ice skated before
[Music]
total grace
you know i could be a figure skater i'd
be a hockey player you would never know
if i showed you that video and i said oh
there's a there's an olympic figure
skater
in his little recreational time with the
family you would believe it wouldn't you
incredible absolutely incredible
and i i went like that for
30 40 seconds
um really great stuff i thought that
would inspire you as well the the the
not inspiring part of the video is you
see everybody else on the ice they're
all wearing masks
it was that was a rather absurd sight
we're outside we're on the ice
people are you know spread apart
and everybody's in masks and they had a
mask patrol i didn't have my mask i had
it on but i had it down
which is how i generally wear my mask i
wear it around my neck because that way
at least i'm protecting my neck from
covid
but i got yelled at like three times in
the span of the 30 or 40 seconds that i
was doing that
the the the mask patrol would just skate
up sir put the mask on
and as i pointed out i did have it on
just didn't have it all the way up
that's all all right here's another good
news new year's resolution for you how
about uh stop wasting your own time time
is money as they say think of think
about all the time you waste in a year
and you you don't want to tally that up
at the end of the year and realize all
the other things you could have been
doing with your time uh here's one way
to save time and save money rockauto.com
okay this is a lot better if you've got
if you need auto parts you can go to the
store you can drive there you can wait
line you can do all that they don't even
have what you need anyway right and they
got to order it online you just wasted
all that time save your time save your
money go to rockauto.com rockauto.com
always offers the lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
tend to do why spend up to twice as much
for the same parts it's really as simple
as that
rockauto.com it's a family business
they've been doing this for a long time
they've been serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years you can go
to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all this is the
main thing prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers if
you don't believe me just go to
rockauto.com yourself and check it out
and you'll see for yourself it's really
easy to navigate and um there's
tons of tons of stuff there right
there's a it's a large catalog but you
can navigate it easily and you'll and
you'll quickly see that things are a lot
cheaper on rockauto.com than they would
be if you went to an auto parts store so
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car truck write
walsh in there how did you hear about
his box so that they know that we sent
you
uh i also want to tell you about this
it's pretty exciting there you know
there's there's a reason millions of
people
believe lies about conservatives we all
deal with this right and that's because
they've been trained to believe those
lies by content creators
uh
entertainers who despise us
and they always say politics is
downstream from culture we as a culture
are starving for content that's edgy and
entertaining and awesome but that
doesn't mock conservative values you
know that's that's not that doesn't
doesn't have it in for us isn't trying
to spread a message that's opposed to
our values
i think we need to give people options
so the daily wires aiming to do just
that what you're about to watch right
now is daily wire's first motion picture
film it's called run hide fight this is
not your stereotypical conservative film
i can tell you that in fact it's
not particularly political at all and
you know i think that's another thing we
all probably would like to see more of
in movies which is less politics
it's not a family-friendly film either
it's intense it's violent and it has a
powerful message to go with it the movie
follows a high school siege by a quartet
of school shooters when one young girl
17 year old zoe hull uses her wits and
her survival skills to fight back let's
take a look at that now
in between breath
take a shot
he's doing really good out there kid
size of that deer we're going to be
eating venison all summer well the day's
work
i think we need to see somebody again
and by what you mean me no i mean us hey
that look in your eye guys in my evening
had that look maybe there's a brochure
you can hear me so i can go
[Music]
is that chris angelic over there is he
doing something completely weird senior
prank day but we'll see all kinds of
dumb stuff today swim captain we'll have
thai food delivered to class and becky
vaughan will set up our homemade slip
and slide this is high school
nothing that happens your matters in the
real world
okay we
are in charge now so please pull out
whichever app you use to do live
streaming video get them up and running
and point it at me now
get down on the ground any more friends
back there
i'm calling 911
you must be close
[Music]
you should be ashamed
very disturbing news out of vernon
central high school
zoey
in between breath
take a shot
go
is it safe to say that this might be our
guardian angel do you want more people
to die that's the last thing i want i'm
gonna kill one person in this room every
five minutes you don't show your face
isn't it ironic that after all your hard
work
people aren't gonna remember you
no
you're gonna remember me
it's a good trailer and you know one
thing i can tell you i've seen the movie
um
and
this is i know it's a concern right any
time
if you hear conservatives are involved
in a movie or you know
people that that uh have a lot of
experience watching like christian
movies this is not a christian movie um
but uh
one thing if you have experience with
that you know that a lot of times the
acting is not great the script is not
great it's just a it's sort of like a
low quality affair uh that is not an
issue here the acting is very good the
lead performance i thought was
spectacular
and the script is very good it
it
engages you right from the very first
frame to the end and that's why we're
excited to show you this film and bring
you something that's never been done
before in conservative media run hide
fight will be available to watch on
friday january 15th at dailywire.com and
we'll be doing a special live stream
premiere the night before on thursday
january 14th on the daily wire youtube
channel let's kick off 2021 by fighting
back on culture and creating our own
content
let's get now to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now today we're canceling not for the
first time probably not the last
cosmopolitan magazine in fairness um
they could be cancelled for literally
everything that's ever been printed in
the pages of their godforsaken
publication but this month's issue i
think warrants a special mention
on the cover is featured in obese woman
smiling proudly with the words
this is healthy
printed across now notice
i want you to notice this how the body
positivity movement
has slid inexorably down the predictable
slippery slope because five years ago
this cover would have looked similar and
had a similar message but instead it
would have said something like
this is beautiful
now it was wrong to call obesity
beautiful but at least you could argue
wrongly in my view but at least
plausibly that beauty is subjective
you know and so you know you can call
anything beautiful
and the benefit for those promoting the
message five years ago was that most
people are too afraid to object thinking
that if they argue that obesity isn't
beautiful it would be the same as saying
that all fat people are ugly of course
it's not the same
it is possible to make the case that
obesity isn't beautiful
which it isn't
without calling all fat people ugly in
the same way that you can make the case
that alcoholism isn't beautiful which it
isn't without calling all alcoholics
ugly it's not the same thing saying
alcoholism isn't beautiful is not the
same thing as saying you're ugly because
you're an alcoholic
two different things
but we've graduated beyond potentially
subjective words like beautiful
and now we're being told that obesity is
actually healthy
and this is the way it always goes this
is always the trajectory
you know the slippery slope is real and
we're on about a thousand different ones
in this culture
so we start by you know the left starts
by demanding that you accept a false but
relatively innocuous or seemingly
well-intentioned premise like obesity is
beautiful
and once your mind has been properly
conditioned they moved to the radical
and dangerous conclusion that was always
embedded in the original premise
which now is obesity is healthy
so let's read a little bit from this
cosmo article it says
it says influencer cali thorpe is one of
social media's best-known advocates of
self-love in 2016 she launched the
community page called the confidence
corner on instagram to spread positivity
to her 250 000 followers but it really
all started with a diet blog in 2012.
quote i thought if i made myself
accountable to strangers i'd lose weight
it made me feel worse than ever she adds
i had a really terrible relationship
with my body growing up i was always i
always struggled with the fact that it
was different to my friends
i tried every single diet
by the way sidebar here
most of the time when people say they
tried every diet the problem is
precisely that they're just trying the
diet
they do it for a few days or a few weeks
and they quit they're dipping their toes
into different diet fads but they give
up as soon as it becomes difficult the
fact is that almost everyone who says
they have they've tried really hard to
lose weight but haven't
uh haven't been able to
in almost all cases
they actually haven't tried hard at all
they may have tried momentarily but not
long enough and not consistent enough
that's a simple reality
the idea that it somehow doesn't work to
eat healthy you know that lots of people
would still be morbidly obese even after
radically altering their diet and
lifestyle to make it more healthy is
just absurd
but getting back to the article it says
these days cali adheres to the body
neutrality movement which focuses on
what your body can do rather than how it
looks
plus size people often feel like they
can't be part of the wellness space
we're trolled for being fat
then then can feel excluded from
exercise because our bodies don't fit
the narrative
first of all you're not being nobody can
be excluded from exercise
if you want to just
lay down on your on your uh
carpet and do some crunches that's you
can't be excluded from doing that
but i mean that that's one excuse to not
exercise i guess
uh you know i was going to go jogging
today but i've been they excluded me
i got excluded from jogging i can't
and from there the article goes on to
chronicle the stories of various other
women some of whom are in fine shape
others who are also morbidly obese the
message is that they've all learned to
love their bodies and that all of their
body types are healthy not surprisingly
no attempt is made to scientifically or
logically defend the proposition that
obesity is healthy it's merely asserted
with an exclamation point and we're
meant to accept it at face value
the only defense is as always an
emotional one the argument seems to be
that obesity is healthy
because it makes fat people feel bad
when you say obesity is not healthy
this is similar to the argument that a
man is a woman because it makes him feel
bad when you say he's not a woman
the irony is that the phrase body
acceptance is used in this article
referring to a woman named jessamine
stanley also obese it says quote
the journey to body acceptance is
something that has taken her a long time
that being jessamine
quote body shaming was one of the first
things i learned to do i grew up in a
community where all of my physical
attributes wide nose big belly big ass
big lips dark skin were deemed ugly
now first of all these things are not
all the same okay
one of these things is not like the
others right the size of your nose your
lips so the the color of your skin these
cannot be naturally changed and they
shouldn't be unnaturally changed either
in my opinion
but the size of your belly can be
changed
and given that an overly bulbous belly
is hazardous to your physical well-being
you should change it
just because there are some things about
yourself that you should proudly embrace
like your skin color your nose size that
doesn't mean that all things about you
should be proudly embraced
but going back to the body acceptance
phrase
it strikes me that this is exactly what
the body acceptance movement is not
doing
body acceptance is what they are
opposing not what they're promoting
you haven't accepted something if you
refuse to acknowledge the full reality
of it
an addict hasn't reached the stage of
acceptance if he's still claiming that
he doesn't that he doesn't have a
problem you aren't accepting your obese
body if you're insisting that it's
healthy and wonderful
that's denial not acceptance
it's the opposite
yes obese people
should accept
that they are obese
and then they should work to change it
because it could very likely kill them
if they don't
that's what acceptance looks like
and this obesity is healthy stuff takes
on an even more sinister tone when you
consider the timing covid is still
surging out there and it's well known
that the obese are especially vulnerable
to it
so you're already more likely to die of
heart disease and dozens of other
complications
due to obesity and covid adds just yet
another danger on top of that
cosmo wants you to embrace that danger
cosmo wants you to be a martyr for body
acceptance
it wants you to love your obesity so
much
that you allow it to kill you
and that's insane
and for that cosmo is canceled
cosmo has the honor of being the first
cancellation of the new year
many more to come
but for now that'll do it for us thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pablo vadosky the show is edited
by danny d'amico our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and production assistant
mckenna waters the madwell show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle well tune in to the
ben shapiro show we'll get a whole lot
of that and much more see you there